Wow the new trailer to x-men 3 the last
end is pretty crazy right just kid kinda
we have our first trailer for Dark
Phoenix which was the x-men movie it was
gonna come out this year then it was
pushed back to next year then there was
a merger between Fox and Marvel people
were like are we still even gonna get
that movie no one's thinking about or
talking about right now of course we're
still gonna get it and now we have a
trailer fine let's just address it it
does kind of look like x-men The Last
Stand right I mean other than the fact
that it doesn't particularly look like a
Last Stand there's no cure for mutants
but in terms of the Phoenix story it
looks very similar and I'm of two minds
on this trailer I really am I'm
literally torn in half one part of me
feels like this looks familiar is [ __ ]
I've seen this before this is the same
Phoenix arc that was in x-men The Last
Stand the other part of me wants to say
well it is a compelling idea that
Charles Xavier repressed a part of Jean
and now it's boiling to the surface and
he has to deal with the sins of the past
so I want to cross my fingers and say
maybe they're promising they'll do the
arc better this time and yeah there is a
scene in this movie you see Jett go up
into space and you see fire so Jean
could get the Phoenix power there from
space it was not like the Phoenix is the
part of her mind that's locked away but
that's just gonna make her angrier and
then that decision-making point is
though genes bad decision-making seems
to be the result of Charles Xavier
[ __ ] with her mind and that's what
x-men the last Stan had freaks me out
because that was the advantageous part
of this whole remake whole thing right
you can go ahead and undo some of the
[ __ ] that happened with x-men what
screams undo like doing the same thing
again and you could make the argument of
Steel Charles Xavier in x-men 3 Charles
Xavier said he did something to jeans
mind so we have to see him do that thing
however counterexample it's also in a
timeline where Charles Xavier and
Magneto met Jean when they both look 60
and Xavier wasn't paralyzed yet so
whatever but the fact that the director
said this does deal with
extraterrestrials and here it looks like
maybe they're doing it right maybe they
just chose not to show it in the trailer
because didn't want to spoil something
in the trailer moving on though
Magneto's bad again magneto man in every
movie no Charles I'm good and now I'm
evil that's the arc right Magneto's
gonna start this movie off is not a bad
guy Dan he's gonna turn back cuz that's
the arc from like first class on Magneto
you OneNote fluttering magneto is pretty
rad I'm just saying they should probably
do something else at the end of
apocalypse when he was good everyone's
like well good magneto I don't know if
someone did someone out there had to
have been like that shit's not gonna
stick you know it
relationship between Charles Xavier and
Erik Lehnsherr it's like Ross and Rachel
or some CW romance they are they aren't
they are they aren't it's like come on
pick a side
[ __ ] break up I do pity the guy though
in about ten years time you're gonna go
from this to this no disrespect to Sir
Ian McKellen but this movie takes place
in the 90s right excellent came out in
2000 its what a few years ten max don't
smoke kids Jessica Chastain's in it as a
blonde I wonder if they're alike all
right we're gonna dye your hair blonde
because we don't want any weird internet
rumors out there about time travel and
its future gene or whatever and is the
internet it'll happen someone dies I see
suits I see funerals who is it let's do
a head count someone out there could
probably piece it together from this
trailer it looks like you could be
entertaining but honestly this movie
it's not on my radar it was on my radar
at the beginning of this year then I got
pushed back I was like okay like I got
other things to look at now I got other
things to worry about it's like oh yeah
x-men god that makeup does get better
every day I look at it in the words of
those punks in the first Ninja Turtles
movie that we're gonna jump April O'Neil
outside her van bad timing
so that's my take on the Dark Phoenix
trailer big part of me thought I've seen
a lot of these arcs before I feel like
I've already seen Magneto's flip-floppy
arc I feel like I've already seen people
give Charles Xavier the I'm not mad I'm
just disappointed I or something he did
to jeans mind in the past in the way of
repressing something there's another
part of me that thinks if you
concentrate on what Charles Xavier did
how it affects him how it affects Jane
making emotional between them and don't
have Jean just off him in a house we
could have ourselves a better version of
that Phoenix saga but I can't help but
look at this Phoenix saga and think
x-men The Last Stand it's just not a
feeling I wanted to walk away from this
trailer right so the trailer too dark
Phoenix have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]